wenn dieses video 15.000 likes bekommen
kaufe ich den und er wird seinen kauf
ich bin und dann stelle ich den immer in
meine videos hinten hintergrund als deko
[Musik]
hier ja was geht kleinen moment so leute
also vor
dieses video hier losgehen da muss ich
sagen das finde ich schade
guck mal ich habe hier noch so einen
richtig guten jay dee lockenstab von
einer verlosung eigentlich schon längst
wechsel da gab es schon eine gewinnerin
die hatte sich auch schon richtig drüber
gefreut problem war nur hat alex einfach
nicht geantwortet ja es ist echt sehr
anstrengend diese gewinne loszuwerden
ich verstehe gar nicht warum wollt ich
finde ich echt geil deswegen jetzt
vielleicht noch mal kurz in diesem video
das aller letzte teil von meiner
verlosung der beste lockenstab der welt
schreibt einen kommentar warum wir ihn
haben wollt und schreibt auf jeden fall
euren instagram namen dazu damit ich
euch besser kontaktieren kann und
abonnieren das ist auch ganz wichtig so
darum sollte heute logischerweise gar
nicht gehen
alex war wieder ein bisschen im internet
unterwegs und hat sich ja was
rausgesucht was ich echt witzig finde
und zwar kennt ihr wahrscheinlich alle
die marke supreme supreme ist zurzeit
mehr gehabt ich verstehe eigentlich gar
nicht warum so klar die sache nicht ganz
schön aber so was ganz besonderes neues
es ist ja irgendwie auch nicht ich habe
davon auch absolut nichts aber ich weiß
wie sehr geheim das zeug ist und ich bin
irgendwie gestern auch sohnes supreme
seite gestoßen und da dachte ich mir den
supreme seife für zehn euro werk auf das
und das hat mich zu dieser heutigen
video idee verleitet wir schauen uns
heute bzw suchen nach den unnötigsten
supreme produkten ich bin gespannt was
wir finden werden aber ich weiß es gibt
werde ich den größten teil also will ich
natürlich gar nicht lange lagern und ich
muss sagen fangen sofort an so leute wir
sind es hier auf google
wir wollen einfach mal so prim eingibt
habe ich gerade schon mal ein bisschen
gemacht hier supreme pizza supreme
taschentücher
das wollen wir nicht sehen wir geben
einfach mal nur hier stream ein
und haben dann halt so ganz normale
produkte wie ich das auch französisches
perlhuhnbrust supreme das habe ich jetzt
vorher noch nicht entdeckt ab jetzt ist
sicher auch nicht original von supreme
aber hier ganz einfach sonst die prämie
die für 21 euro gefolgt von ebay oder
den hierfür 23 euro das ist diese fake
scheiße glaube ich also um diese ganz
normale sachen hiervon von supreme soll
es heute gar nicht gehen was ist es also
ich glaube man kann da gerade nicht
bestellt stimmt da war was also t shirts
hoodies einmal außen vor gelassen jacken
oder sonst was also wie schon gesagt was
mich auf dieses video gebracht hat das
war diese supreme seite habe ich
irgendwie hast dann auf facebook gesehen
oder so ist eine seite von supreme kann
man irgendwie kaufen für 12 euro war das
oder acht euro keine ahnung ja und dann
habe ich einfach mal weiter gesucht und
bin auf den unschlagbaren die hre
gekommen mir hier einfach mal einen
supreme hammer zu kaufen wir reden hier
von einem ganz normalen hama seien
hunger haben hast vorne hier eisen holz
hinten ran kannst im beirat für zehn
euro kaufen zu prima dachte sicher
hammergeil das fest zum beispiel wir
machen jetzt auch in hama aber da ist
nichts zu tun hammer ist kann man denen
ich einfach mal eben für 12 euro kaufen
ein
der kostet 200 euro nur weil supreme
drauf steht aber der ist sogar mit
spitze vorne dran und ausverkauft so
wenn man hier einfach mal weiter runter
geht sieht man hier auch ein supreme
erworben so was hatte ich als ich abitur
gemacht habe habe ich glaube ich für
vier euro gekauft supreme hupe für 50
euro
leider auch ausverkauft man so das sind
aber welche sachen da kann ich noch
überlegt schon an solch okay ich frag
mich zwar ernsthaft wie marken
orientiert ein mensch sein muss um sich
ein hammer fuß ohne teure zu kaufen
kauft die anscheinend besser und werde
sich ausverkauft so und jetzt haltet
euch fest was ich gefunden habe
wir haben hier ein supreme rasierer für
200 euro plus 499 versand dann gut man
muss sagen dieser rasierer sieht
qualitativ hochwertig aus ich finde das
supreme nur darauf auch gar nicht so
schlecht aber ganz ehrlich
200 euro
ist so viel zu viel ich mein gut der
kostet vielleicht 40 also nur das modell
an sich ne das ist doch so gestört
lieferungen des spätestens aus berlin
gut dann gibt es eben noch supreme
rasierer gar kein problem
supreme xl objektkunst feuerlöscher deko
199 euro will der kann ja nicht mal
feuer löschen
ich verstehe die welt nicht mehr
verkaufe einen einzigartigen kunst
feuerlöscher rot lackiert mit weißem
supreme schriftzug gibt es sonst
nirgends zu kaufen der feuerlöscher ist
zwar gefüllt aber durch die
neulackierung gebe ich keine garantie
auf die funktion und bieten da als deko
elemente muss man sich so wie heißt der
typ der den verkauft keine ahnung typ
steht morgens auf habe heute mal wieder
nichts zu tun was machen war ich hab's
wir machen einfach ein supreme
feuerlöscher wenn dieses video 15.000
likes bekommen kaufe ich den ohne wird
es dann kaufe ich den und dann stelle
ich den immer in meine videos hinten
hintergrund als deko und irgendwann
probiere ich denn vielleicht dann auch
mal aus wut mehr produkte als ein stream
hammer supreme feuerlöscher stream seife
supreme hupe gibt sicherlich nicht oder
wer hätte es gedacht natürlich gibt es
auch noch eine supreme zahnbürste für 20
euro vietoris in zahnbürsten
ich glaube 169 habe ich letztens
zahnbürsten gekauft drei stück gegen
diesen die komische supreme zahl müsste
brathwaite skateboard street ist das
erste zahn wirst du das skateboard
zahnbürste von supreme und sofort sind
die zähne noch sauberer leute das müsst
ihr euch merken supreme zahnbürsten sind
die besten was ich mich dann wirklich
mal gefragt habt nachdem ich alle diese
blöden produkte gefunden habt gibt es
vielleicht auch irgendwie in supreme
berger oder supreme pizza und ich habe
einfach mal ein game supreme pizza und
sehe hier wagner big pizza supreme und
ich dachte mir sofort zu nein lass das
jetzt bitte keine kooperation zwischen
dem pizza hersteller wagner und der
marke supreme sein und ich bin drauf
gegangen
und weiß man erleichtert dass das glaube
ich nicht so ist die pizza heißt supreme
soll denke ich mal eine amerikanische
pizza sein also viel käse ist echt geil
ich glaube ich habe sogar schon mal
probiert aber wenn ich mir jetzt diese
ganzen pizzen janko ich hunger und an
dieser stelle bin ich jetzt echt
erleichtert
ich glaube das ist nicht offiziell von
supreme diese pizza hier und ich gehe
stark davon aus diese pizza führt dann
wahrscheinlich 18 euro auch nicht obwohl
sie echt ganz lecker aussieht dann aber
der sache die ich finde ich echt
unterstützen kann ich meine wer kennt es
nicht draußen ist es dunkel
man sieht nicht ganz genau wo man lang
gehen muss da gibt es jetzt eine ganz
einfache lösung hier soll das supreme
flashlight taschenlampe für 80 euro
gar kein problem da kann man auf jeden
fall zu schlagen und schwupps weiß man
wo es lang geht also da sag ich mal
wirklich das ist auf jeden fall 80 euro
wert war natürlich nur spaß und das
ganze doch so ein bisschen abzurunden
habe ich hier gerade
[Musik]
um dem ganzen jetzt aber so ein kleiner
abschluss hier zu verleihen habe ich
noch ein schönes foto gefunden was das
ganze ziemlich gut beschreibt und zwar
haben wir hier einmal ein normales
kondom für 649 schon recht viel und 1
supreme kondom für 649 euro
er hat disziplin kondome gibt es
natürlich auch das waren 10 der uniti
ist noch über teuersten supreme produkte
der welt ich hoffe dass wieder hat euch
gefallen bei 15.000 likes habe ich bald
ein feuerlöscher mehr in meiner wurde
obwohl ich noch eigentlich gar kein
feuer das in meiner wohnung habe
eigentlich gar nicht schlecht also leute
check snapshot und instagram ab wir
sehen uns morgen wieder am morgen gibt's
neues video
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen tag